Edge of Eternity spoilers are cool and
all, but the biggest news so far is
definitely this. As long as it's
legendary and has a power and toughness,
it can be a commander. Not sure about
you, but the moment I read this, I knew
which one I was building. But first,
let's break the ice. My name is Jin and
this is Next Level Commander. Please
subscribe if you like magic and
commander. That's all I do. And now,
let's introduce our commander. Buckle
up, fellow captains. No, seriously,
buckle up. Because the RMS Titanic is
our ship. Insurance fraud is the game.
And in this case, our opponents are the
space icebergs. I guess we be crashing
into them for unsinkable wealth, which
brings us closer to our end goal. More
crashing. Seems good. Looking at this
ship, we have some work to do. I mean,
it's got the best evasions, and seven
power is the magical number. Yes, the
crashing part makes it slightly more
difficult, but we'll figure something
out. It also generates a ton of resource
which we can build around and whenever
you build around something we have to
make sure it happens as consistently as
possible. We must crash and burn. I see
now we're on the same page of the
insurance document. We have a very
fraudulent 10 minutes coming up. But
before we go anywhere, we need some
pilots. The hiring criteria is simple,
three power or bigger and as felonious
as possible. Foundry Inspector is our
primary candidate. Not only does it
single-handedly cruise the ship, it also
allows us to cheap out on the
construction. I mean, on a mission where
failure is success, cutting corners is a
must. Scrapler, we might not have as
many large artifacts to recur the
Titanic itself with, but the boatload of
other artifacts getting scrapped over
and over should make this an all-star
anyways. Megas of the wheel, we'll be
seeing tons of wheels in this deck, but
one that can also hold the wheel is an
easy include. Treasure nabber. Let's
just say what we borrow for the day
might end up getting melted down into, I
don't know, another Titanic.
Kazul, our opponents might get
suspicious and send in some creatures to
see what's going on. Let's just say the
investigation will be ogre real fast.
Ingenious artillerists turns our pay out
into artillery. Game will be over quick
with this one out. Hellite Corser
dragging our ship out of the junkyard
and cruise it with haste. Perfect Midame
pilot choice. Zenith Chronicler. Yeah,
we're pretty desperate for card draw.
This does help our opponents sometimes,
but I'm sure we can use the cards better
with how much mana we're making.
Cryptothraw. Our game plan does hinge a
fair bit on our Titanic connecting. So,
a three power static protection option
is always good. Scrapwater. If you think
we can't get away with more bamboozling,
surprise, we can. Insurance companies
hate this one trick. If we read the fine
print correctly, we see that Titanic's
ability doesn't say if you do. So in
response to the trigger, we can
sacrifice it to something else. Scrap
water for example and still get the
payout. Aldrazi line breaker crewing our
ship and giving it haste and a plus one
to boot. Just make sure you crew before
entering combat or Titanic isn't a valid
target. Civil line soothsayer a nice
early three drop that brings something
larger on later turns. Good value.
Sunset Strike Master helps cast Titanic
on turn three and Cruzen on turn four.
Sold. Grabby Giant like Sunset
Strikemaster. Getting this in the
opening hand means we'll be attacking
with Titanic on turn four, the latest.
And after that, we can convert our
treasures into cards. Expensive, but can
definitely be relevant. Lorine, as we
mentioned earlier, we might have some
trouble defending ourselves. So, gold is
pretty clutch here. Diverting our
opponent's biggest creatures into each
other while we continue with our ship
smuggling business. That's worth
sacrificing a few treasures for Fared.
Artifacts will come and go in this deck
a lot and we'll get a ton of scraps
which we can use to turn into loot or do
more goating. Or brasque the hidden
expensive but creatures that can crew
and give haste are far and few between.
Also, just look at him sneaking in the
furnace rooms definitely passes the
fraud test. Another all-star is
Quicksmith Genius. Our guy is
responsible for driving and the looting
when it all goes down in flames. Skyfire
Phoenix, the most resilient of them all.
Don't matter if it's dead. As long as we
put Titanic onto the stack, whether it's
from our hand, command zone, or anywhere
else, the Phoenix will be there to
ignite the engines. Now, we have a few
more crew members that aren't quite
there in physique, but more than makes
up for it in Malevolence.
They're not driving the ship alone, but
can definitely work together or recruit
the help of some lands, I guess. Crime
novelist will help double our prize
money by publishing Chronicles of Our
Heist. Professional phase breaker turns
our treasures and our opponent's broken
noses into more cards. Silent Arbiter
keeps the traffic slow for only the most
important creatures or ships. Mishra and
the mirrors help ramp out our commander.
Magda functions a bit like a mirror in
the early game, but later can also
provide tons of utility. Liberator
urgter protects our ship from sorcery
speed removals and giving half our deck
flash just is just too good to pass up.
Okay, now that we have our ship crewed,
we need to begin the crashing. No, not
next turn. Immediately. We can't risk
our ship being target practice for our
opponents. Oh, yeah. Also, we need some
protection spells just to be double
sure. And if our opponents somehow have
large flying blockers, cuz I mean,
dragons been popular these days. Not
sure why. Well, we crash into the
vulnerable ones first. But cards like
Shandra's Ignition and Nebble Hammer
Flame should also help clear the way
when push comes to shove. All right,
we're going in.
Lookout is raining insurance money. Once
we get the payout, we need to cash it
in, and it will always need more cards
to set up for the next operation. I
don't usually play wheels, but I think
they're needed here. And thanks to the
abundance of mana, sandstone oracle, and
even coslike itself isn't too
far-fetched. And now we have the crew,
the funds, and intel, we aim to crash
again and again until there's nothing
left to crash into. Detti is the go-to
guy for restoration, and I just went to
their EDH page and found some
refurbishing tools. Trust for treasure,
goblin welder, scarecrow, and nim death
mantle. Or alternatively, with some ice
cold slide of hand, we can rescue the
ship just after it does damage to the
iceberg, but just before it takes
repercussion damage. Let that sink in. I
can't tell you how it works, but I know
Isaac Newton is rolling in his grave. In
Space Magic, there are no rules.
Actually, Voyager Staff does it even
better and will be an all-star in this
deck with all the artifact recursion.
Meanwhile, we can also head to the
trading post to exchange some extra
pilots for the ship back. It's great. Or
start a little revolution where we beat
people up for not letting us retrieve
our Titanic. And now that we got our
host covered, it's time to go above and
beyond. Why settle for seven when it can
be 14 or 28 if we take a small detour to
magical Christmas land. The other palm
spells are not as good, but the magical
number here is four, making our ship a
two hit kill on even the toughest
icebergs. Throw in some protection spell
and other utility, and we have a deck.
Now, in its core, this is a monoret
artifacts deck, somewhat similar to the
daddy lists, but our commander serves as
a value engine and the win condition.
We're dedicating a lot of resources to
push it through, but the reward is
fairly reasonable. This list is
mid-budget and mid high complexity to
play, but just think of the fraud jokes
and Titanic puns you can make.
All right, this is Jyn with Next Level
Commander. If you like this kind of
content, subscribe for more because I
know this won't be the only vehicle
commander I'll be building. See you
soon. Thanks for watching.
And they offered me so much money.